when you're with a child you're always
guiding them to appropriate behavior
that's in accordance with your values if
your value is respect for other people
you're guiding the child so that they
are noticing how other people react if
they're at the playground and they grab
the bucket from the other child we're
gonna say oh look at her face she was
using the bucket we need to give that
bucket back to her so we're always
setting that limit we're not making an
excuse for our child to run roughshod
over the world so there's a lot of
talking about what everybody needs but
in a very matter-of-fact way we're not
making our child wrong and bad for
taking the bucket or running in front of
the waiter we're correcting them
essentially but before we correct we
connect oh you wanted to run and look
out the window that's why you ran in
front of the waiter of course and
remember we talked about this we need to
stay in our seat there's no shame and
guilt matter of fact if your child
willingly gives off that bucket or even
grudgingly gives up the bucket for
something they want more which is the
relationship with you when he's 10 and
you say it's time to stop building with
your Legos and go to bed or whatever
he's doing he's like
mom you say I know you love doing that
and it's time to get ready for bed he's
gonna again he's built the neural wiring
he's able to do that when he's 14 and
his buddies say come on smoke some weed
with us behind the school he's like
really want to do that but I really
don't want to get kicked off the soccer
team I'm going to choose the soccer team
right he's developed the neural wiring
for self-discipline but what would have
happened if we just grabbed the bucket
away no moral wiring gets built he's not
actually making a choice when we don't
set limits children don't learn
self-discipline because they're never
asked to give up the thing they want for
what they want more but also when we are
authoritarian about it when we're strict
parents they also don't willingly give
it up because the discipline isn't
internal it's external no go take your
bath right now they're not developing
internal self-discipline and then it
more becomes about hiding from the
authority to get away with things which
is what happens when they become
teenagers exactly
that was Dr Laura Markham a clinical
psychologist mother and founder of aha
parenting an incredible online resource
for parents looking to build more
connection and raise happy competent
responsible and considerate kids she's
the best-selling author of two books
peaceful parent happy kids and peaceful
parent happy siblings and inspires
parents every day to choose connection
and coaching over punishment and control
even having read many different
parenting books myself I've never quite
found a resource as practical and easy
to implement as all that Dr Laura shares
I feel honored to have had her on my
podcast and ask her many of the
questions I have myself in raising our
children we discuss anything and
everything from a sibling rivalry to if
peaceful parenting creates weak and
entitled children to the secret every
parent needs to know about saying no and
my favorite part specific Solutions and
responses to Common scenarios in raising
kids this is one I'll be listening to
over and over again myself for reminders
as I navigate the parenting Journey
because none of us are perfect and these
reminders are true sources of
inspiration to take on each new day as
our best selves for our kids welcome to
the Ellen Fisher podcast let's get
started
[Music]
okay I know you know we can all use a
little support when it comes to staying
on top of our nutrition with busy lives
children and the sometimes seemingly
never-ending to-do list along with
eating a Whole Foods plant-based diet to
help me feel my best and most vibrant
self I am obsessed with anima Mundi
herbal's beautiful selection of products
founded by herbalist Adriana ayalas
anema Mundi is an apothecary which uses
over 200 different sustainably grown
herbs from around the world to create
intentional products that contains zero
fillers binders or flow agents they're
made in the US with certified organic
wild crafted and sustainably harvested
plants and herbs in a vegan and
cruelty-free kitchen they also use
eco-friendly packaging recyclable glass
or biodegradable bags I love the
immunity boosters in their shop
including the black elderberry syrup
mushroom mocha milk and spirulina which
is an organic protein-rich mineralizer
that tastes delicious in banana mango
smoothies I got a discount code for you
guys so just enter the code Ellen 20 for
20 off your order click the link in my
show notes low to get this deal
[Music]
thank you Dr Laura for being here I am
so excited for this conversation and to
pick your brain on all things parenting
and I definitely find your resources to
be extra easy to understand a lot of
times when I'm reading conscious
parenting respectful parenting gentle
parenting whatever you want to call it
resources I'm inspired but then I feel a
little bit like okay but how do I do
that you know and I just feel like a
little like I'm left hanging a little
bit but when I go to your website aha
parenting there's such clear easy
Direction on look this is this is how
you can respond to the specific scenario
and it's very helpful because then the
more you practice it the easier it
becomes so thank you for being here my
pleasure so first thing I want to ask
you is what made you realize I need to
get this message out there and help
parents about parenting our kids well
when I had my son I was finishing my PhD
in Clinical Psychology but they don't
teach you a lot about parenting but you
do learn about psychology and here I was
with this baby and I was around other
new parents and I saw that they
well they hadn't read the same research
articles I had clearly and they were
having such a hard time in general
parenting is stressful and they didn't
have a lot of support and I realized
that
we're you know babies brains when
they're born are pretty unformed babies
neurology take shape
in response to the experience the baby
has not one experience you know if you
yelled at your child once you're it's
not going to change your baby's brain
but babies and children their brains are
still forming and they form in response
to repeated experience
and I realize the parents around me
didn't didn't know that and didn't have
the support they needed to give their
babies and children
the support to shape brains and nervous
systems that would be the best they
could be in their lives so I wanted to
to support parents to do that yeah and I
think a lot of times as parents we're
just initially start raising our kids in
the way that we know how the way that we
were raised of course and then we don't
know really any other way yes but I
think there's a lot of people especially
people listening that are like I want I
want to be the best parent I can be for
my kids yes so what is the issue with
kind of the opposite of what you
advocate for like strict parenting like
what are the problems there so
conventional parenting in the United
States and really the whole Western
World conventional parenting says that
children should behave well it's all
about appearances it's not about how the
child feels it's not about the skills
the child is developing to manage their
own emotions
it's not about self-knowledge for the
child which is important for the child
to learn to manage themselves and it's
also not about the parent-child
connection conventional parenting is
like manipulation it's a set of
strategies right and it's about love
withdrawal conventional parenting says
if you don't do what I want you to do
I am going to withdraw my love I'm going
to send you to the naughty step you
think about what you've done here and
that's a sand in that's a symbol of what
I actually could do I could put you out
the door
and that sounds extreme but there is a
parenting expert who I won't name who in
her book
describes how her four-year-old wouldn't
brush her teeth and she was tired of
that struggle and she took the
four-year-old and put her outside on the
family deck it was in the winter the
child had her nightgown on and no shoes
now to be fair it was California so it
wasn't in the snow or anything but it
was cold she put the child outside in
the dark and shut the door a
four-year-old
that's
um that's conventional parenting
taken a step further it says to the
child if you don't do what I want I will
cast you out
what we say to the child is
we love you you're okay the way you are
in fact we adore you the way you are you
can't always act out all those big
feelings you have but all the feelings
are understandable because you're human
and we'll help you manage them we've got
you I think that like a lot of times
parents are like yeah I don't want to
get to that place or you know maybe your
example or yelling or threatening or
counting to count to three or else you
know a lot of times parents think I
don't know what else to do to get my
kids to listen so why why are we acting
that way why do we get to that place of
course and there are two reasons we get
to that place one is that some kids are
more difficult than other kids
anyone who's been around a lot of
children knows they're all different and
it's not just how they're raised they're
all born different right so some kids
are more challenging they're more
sensitive they have sensory Pro you know
they they experience the world
differently than than maybe I do or you
do so kids are different that's one
reason it's hard for parents there's
another reason though
when we parent conventionally we are
undermining the relationship the natural
relationship we have with our child
conventional parenting that uses threats
and Punishment
imagine if you were married to someone
who used threats and Punishment on you
would you feel close to them no of
course not no and so children don't know
enough to articulate that but they don't
feel close to us when we do that and
they act out so that's a reason parents
are you know parents say he's driving me
crazy well he's driving you crazy
because he doesn't feel connected he's
either trying to get your attention or
your approval or he's given up on it and
he's out for number one because he
doesn't think there's anyone in his
corner right so of course that of the
effect on the parent is for the parent
to think the child is a brat the child's
just difficult they can't get the child
to do what they want unless they you
know how conventional parenting works
you threaten if it doesn't work you have
to threaten something more so you're
always upping the ante and meanwhile
you're destroying your relationship with
your child basically because you're
causing more and more tension and a lot
of it I've heard you say it comes out of
fear which is so true when I break it
down almost every one of my moments that
are like oh that was a low parenting
moment or oh I didn't do my best it's
because I was acting out of fear or I
wasn't well taken care of myself and I
was yes I was on edge because I didn't
get enough sleep or I didn't get my
shower that I really wanted and you know
things basic needs that I need to be met
so that I'm the best human I can be for
my kids so can we talk a little bit
about like the fear based aspect the
fear absolutely and I think this is a
perfect opportunity for us to just be
really clear for everyone watching
every parent has low parenting moments
every human has times when we aren't at
our best that's how we learn that's how
we grow use that you know it's not a
mistake if you learn from it right and I
just think parents need to um maybe the
most important thing parents can do is
put themselves back on their list so
they do meet their own needs that was a
beautiful description of what we're not
at our best if we don't get enough sleep
if we don't eat when we're hungry and
Etc right and when we do mess up
self-compassion it is the most important
thing we can do is to forgive ourselves
and to say yes it's hard it's hard to be
a parent and then to see what we can do
differently the next day and apologize
to our children when we make mistakes
yes and if we you know some parents are
reluctant to apologize because they
think it diminishes their stature
so not true your child knows what you
did yeah if you don't apologize why
should your child learn to apologize
number one yes yes that's what I say all
the time and and also if we don't
apologize there's a way in which not
only don't we repair the relationship
with our child we don't if we don't
apologize also we don't repair our own
sense of self we walk around feeling
like oh I did mess up I mess up if we
can redeem ourselves with our child and
remake that repair we can feel better
about ourselves we can let go of that
guilt and that shame because shame and
guilt are not going to make us better
parents we need to repair that so we can
move on with our head held high and be
the best parent we can be tomorrow yeah
and some of my most pivotal connection
moments with my kids are when I am
saying sorry and then they're saying oh
wow Mom humbling herself like oh my mom
sees me Mom feels my my frustration mom
cares yeah and then there's like such a
great connection moment even from there
so I love that you said that I think
it's so important for people to hear
that it doesn't not only doesn't it
diminish you you can come out of that
disruption in your relationship stronger
you can you you and your child come out
with a better relationship after that
and I think a lot of times people want
to separate well kids are different than
any of these adult examples you're
giving but can you touch a little bit on
that aspect because when you give that
example of look if you treated your kids
the way that you treat your spouse or
the way that you treat your friends like
how close would your would your your
loved ones feel to you how much would
they like being around you and a lot of
times I think people want to say well
it's different it's different because
they're kids like what what's your
response to that so yes it's different
because we are in a position with our
children where we need to
um set boundaries sometimes we do need
to set limits it in fact if you're a
parent all day every day you're probably
setting limits right on the other hand
it's not different at all your child is
a human being and the same
um factors that govern any human being
psyche govern your child which is that
your child notices when they're treated
with respect versus disrespect with
affection and warmth and understanding
versus orders yes and also I mean you
can relay this to let's say you're in a
partner relation a partner example where
one is maybe not acting like their best
self because that's kind of what we're
relating to kids like okay their brain
is still developing they have a lot of
learning to do so we're there to guide
them but even in a relationship with
adults one or the other could be having
a low moment and they're not being their
best self like what's going to help you
get out of that moment is it when the
other yells at you shames you refuses to
talk to you or whatever has you know
punishments or is it like a loving
Embrace acknowledging your feelings even
if the other thinks that the feelings
feelings are silly because you know I
have a lot of feelings I have a lot of
emotions that my husband sometimes is
like okay another another emotion let's
all right here we go you know because
you just not he just doesn't operate the
same like you know place that I do but
him willing to care about my feelings
regardless of the feeling helps me in my
lowest moments so I feel like that's a
good example I think that's beautifully
said and and I would argue that you know
we could say from this oh will children
have these inconvenient feelings well
children give us the tremendous gift of
presence they're fully present in the
moment that's why their feelings are so
big that
their presence is such a gift to us
right it just like I would argue that
you're a person with big feelings you
know your husband's in love with you
partly because you bring those big
feelings to every aspect of your
relationship and he loves that about you
even if at times it's inconvenient yeah
the same thing is true for our
relationship with our children what a
gift it is for us that they have these
big feelings even though at times we
need to help them to learn to manage
them and that doesn't that doesn't
happen by our saying
manage your feelings it happens by us
saying oh you're really upset right now
about this I see that tell me more and
you can always you don't have to throw
that to show me how upset you are you
can always tell me and I will always
listen and try to help you right so that
that's how kids learn to manage their
feelings yeah totally yeah so now I want
to ask you a very specific question that
I hear sometimes that respectful
parenting gentle parenting causes and
creates weak and entitled children
what what are your thoughts on that well
first we should probably
uh Define respectful or gentle parenting
you you know conscious parenting
peaceful parenting there's a lot of
words for this and
what we're really talking about is
respect for this other human being and
showing up in relationship with this
other human being in a way that is for
their highest good
because that is our responsibility we
said it is different than a relationship
with another adult we're not actually
responsible for the well-being of most
of the people we interact with we are we
took on the responsibility when we
decided to have a child we may not have
understood what we were doing but we did
take on the responsibility which is a
sacred responsibility right so we need
to show up in a way that is for their
highest good and we don't have to be
perfect as we've already said when we
repair we can even strengthen the
relationship right
okay so
um that's respectful parenting I think
would be it's not enough to say that but
that is what that's the kernel of what
we're talking about my particular
approach which I call peaceful parenting
is it's all about the relationship it's
all about the connection with the child
right and it's about coaching the child
to be their best self instead of
resorting to control
rewards punishment threats yelling okay
so that's those are the two big Ideas
right we connect and we coach the child
which includes emotion coaching and it
also includes setting up the environment
for the child to thrive that might mean
bedtime it might mean fewer screens it
might mean less sugar whatever it you
know Maria Montessori said don't try to
control the child control the
environment so the child can Thrive
that's part of coaching right an emotion
coaching we can talk more about and give
some examples but emotion coaching helps
kids with their emotions so those are
the first two big ideas but notice
what's missing here no parent who is
has not had any sleep who has you know
dysregulated who is upset and who
believes that their child is um going to
be a spoiled brat if they if they
empathize with them that parent cannot
actually offer the child connection that
parent cannot actually coach they're
going to resort to control out of their
own fear that this child is going to be
a brat right so the third big idea in my
Approach peaceful parenting is parents
have to self-regulate that means you
have to take care of yourself it means
you have to work on your issues that get
triggered so that you can show up as the
parent you want to be and be present
with your child yes I love that yeah so
those are the three ideas so the
question is does that produce a spoiled
brat if you think that you will act out
of your fear and when we act out of fear
we go to the lowest place we can come
from when we act out of fear and we're
always sorry later if you if if anyone
listening reflects on their life and
they think those times
when my heart is overflowing with love
and I relate to the people around me
from that versus those times when I'm
I'm scared and I'm notice how I just
tightened up like you could just feel
your heart tighten up you feel your
stomach tighten up you don't respond
from fear in a way that supports anyone
else's growth or your own you don't
support connection you res when we get
scared we control that's what humans do
because we're frightened so if you come
from that perspective you can guarantee
that your child will not be okay you're
undermining the relationship
so I think when people say that the fear
they're really expressing is
if I empathize with my child and they
are allowed to have these big feelings
they will be out of control and they'll
act badly so I would say to that parent
they're confusing two things they're
confusing the emotions and the Behavior
now all Behavior does come from emotions
but all Emotions Don't Have To result in
Behavior I may be quite angry at someone
but I'm not going to hit them I'm not
even going to yell at them
I'm gonna look at what's going on for me
that I'm angry at them maybe they've
trespassed some boundary that's
important to me right and I'm going to
express that in words what we have found
through research is that when you
express something in words you don't
actually have to act it out to the
degree that your child can put into
words how angry they are at their little
brother
they don't have to hit the little
brother right right so our job as
parents is to say to our kids you can be
as mad as you want to at your brother
you can be as mad as you feel you tell
me about it I hear you oh and he wrecked
your you got that trophy for your sports
and he wrecked your trophy and you told
him not to play with that no wonder
you're mad of course sweetheart right it
sounds like you have something really
important to tell your brother right
I'll help come with me I'll help I'll be
with you while you tell your brother
right and you're also making sure he's
not going to scream at his two-year-old
brother and you know you're you're
protecting both kids but also teaching
them to advocate for themselves right
but notice you're not letting them go
smash his little brother right right
even verbally right so I think that when
parents say
gentle parenting produces a spoiled brat
maybe they've seen someone who says
they're doing gentle parenting who
doesn't set limits that's entirely
possible
or maybe it's just Their Fear talking
that they think that a child who's
allowed to have feel their feelings when
they when you acknowledge feelings that
somehow that is bad I think humans
always have feelings and feelings are
fine and they are part of our experience
of being human and we can express those
and the more our feelings are
acknowledged the less we will Express
those feelings in ways that are harmful
to other people and the more that we're
modeled the behavior and emotion
self-regulated emotions from our parents
yes and I think also the easier it
becomes as we become adults maybe to not
be super triggered or extra sensitive
like you still have your feelings but
maybe to not such a high degree where
like little things can hyper trigger you
because the way that your parents
responded was little things didn't
trigger them no question you know we
talked about the brain and the nervous
system
[Music]
okay you guys if you haven't purchased
anything from Indigo Lona yet you are
totally missing out you know how a lot
of yoga wear can ride up in
uncomfortable ways or just isn't super
flattering while Indigo Luna is
different I am constantly finding myself
reaching in my closet for a piece from
Indigo Luna because everything in their
shop is made to hug your curves in all
the right places that not only holds
your body well it also fits comfortably
and is super flattering if you don't
know what Indigo Luna is they're
ethically made yoga wear swimwear
Intimates and More Beautiful simple
shapes earthy colors and plant dyes from
recycled or organic materials they are
slow fashion and sustainably sourced so
everything is cut sewn and dyed by a
loving human hand and they ensure that
every person involved in production
Works in comfortable safe conditions the
layless layers and Roxy crop top are my
favorite to wear around the house and
the Tula Poncho is the coziest sweater
I've ever worn it's oversized warm and
ethically knitted in Bali from deadstock
acrylic yarn that would otherwise have
gone to the landfill you can dress it up
or down but no matter what you'll feel
cozy and beautiful in it so I got you
guys a discount code just enter the code
Ellen 10 for 10 of your order or click
the link in the show notes
when children get yelled at on a regular
basis
or when they get spanked
people have all kinds of reasons to
spank you know they might say well the
Bible says so and I would just say there
are plenty of people who've written
about this who say you have to you can
have different interpretations of what
the Bible says for instance but we know
that when children are spanked for any
reason or hit or yelled at even on a
regular basis what ends up happening is
the brain becomes reactive that the
amygdala the alarm system these two
little almond-shaped places in your
brain go alarm alarm whenever anything
happens it feels like a threat so when
the little brother takes something of
theirs and breaks it
to them that's an alarm going off right
yeah and they will respond the way
they've been treated often right yeah if
the parents respond to an emergency by
screaming at the kids that child will
respond as if it's an emergency and
scream at his brother or me even hit him
or then there's also I feel like another
scenario where the child goes Inward and
they're on the outside behaving in a way
that maybe you think is optimal but then
maybe on the inside they might not be
regularly in their emotions well is that
also something do you think that's valid
I think that's totally valid think about
the number of adults you know who try so
hard as adults to be good
good little girl or a good little boy
right somewhere inside them there's
somebody who doesn't feel okay about
themselves there's all that shame and
guilt and they those feelings are so
hard to live with because they're
beating up on themselves all the time
right and they end up drinking too much
smoking too much weed doing you know
sometimes other addictions like shopping
we do things to make ourselves feel
better because we have these terrible
ways of treating ourselves and that
starts in childhood whatever voice our
parents used with us routinely becomes
our own inner voice and the way we treat
ourselves so most of us have some
healing to do there as I said
self-compassion of re of beginning to
talk to ourselves like it's someone we
love absolutely and is there any
research in regards to this like
comparison aspect of the different types
of parenting oh yes lots lots
psychologists I'm guessing it's showing
all these things that you're saying so
conventional parenting is often referred
to as control parenting in the research
and you look at discipline techniques
that parents use and if parents resort
to control strategies to get their child
to behave those children are more likely
to treat treat their siblings badly
that's one research study
um it's a bunch of research it actually
makes so much sense because they're
being controlled so then they're wanting
to control the smaller person in their
life because the bigger people in their
life are controlling them and dictating
them maybe more than what's healthy
right and then they yes and then they
want to do the same to their little
little sibling I've definitely seen that
in my own family even there are certain
times where I'm seeing you know my older
siblings treat the younger siblings in a
certain way I'm like oh wait wait don't
do that oh wait I've done that I've done
that to them you know yeah and I've had
parents say to me that they hear the
same words coming out of their child's
mouth that they use toward their child
right and of course the opposite is also
true that parents who are more empathic
with their child when they say oh I see
you're really you really wish I would
say yes to this and we can't do it now
it's time for dinner now but I hear how
much you wish you could that when you
know tomorrow they'll hear their from
the they're making dinner and they hear
in the other room the older sister
saying to the younger child you know oh
I know you wish you could play with this
and right now I'm playing with it but
you could have it after me or something
yeah so we definitely have that in our
family too with all the different ages
we have like I've definitely I've
definitely seen that it's like oh those
moments like yeah oh yay okay I'm doing
something right and then going back to
what you said about parenting where
someone thinks it's gentle parenting but
but what is actually happening is there
aren't any boundaries I think that's a
very common misconception people have
about peaceful respectable parenting
that oh you just have no boundaries and
your kids walk all over you and they get
whatever they want in life and then
they're going to grow up to be entitled
like I see how they get to that place
yes if they've seen that in real life so
how can we explain that confusion for
because I think some people do get
confused they go oh yes I love the idea
connection connecting with my child you
know and then it goes to a place where
there aren't boundaries if they're not
be careful yeah so I think it when
you're with a child you're always
guiding them
you're trying to take your cues from the
child right but you're always guiding
them to appropriate behavior that's in
accordance with your values if your
value is respect for other people
you're guiding the child so that they
are noticing how other people react so
if they're at the playground and they
grab the bucket from the other child
we're not going to let that happen right
we're going to say oh look at her face
she was using the bucket she wants the
bucket
we need to give that bucket back to her
or did you did you ask her if she's done
with it yet we need to find out when
she'll be done and maybe she'll let you
use it after that you want to give the
bucket back and ask her so we're always
setting that limit we're not making an
excuse for our child to run roughshod
over the world and when we take our
child to a restaurant we're not letting
the child run around the restaurant
under other people's feet unless that's
the ethos of that restaurant if it's on
the beach and that's what people do
that's fine but in general we're going
to have a conversation before we go into
the restaurant and say what's
everybody's job in the restaurant yes
the wait staff's job is to get that food
hot food out of the kitchen safely and
onto our table such a gift to us that
we're going to be able to eat that food
what would happen if we ran under their
feet while they were trying to do that
uh oh that would be a mess and we talked
to our kids about it so there's a lot of
um talking about what everybody needs
but in a very matter of fact way we're
not making our child wrong and bad for
taking the bucket or running in front of
the waiter but we are we are saying and
and also we're correcting them
essentially right but before we correct
we connect oh you wanted to run and look
out the window that's why you ran in
front of the waiter of course and
remember we talked about this we need to
stay in our seat right oh of course you
want to use a red bucket because Red's
your favorite color and that's her
bucket notice I'm saying and
sometimes when you say but it sort of
invalidates what came before yeah right
we're saying and all things can be true
at once and our child is not bad and
wrong there's no shame and guilt matter
of fact and when can we when can we do a
matter of fact when we get away from our
own fear if our fear says everyone in
the restaurant is staring at me or the
other parents at the playground are
staring at me then we're going to be I
told you not to take that bucket and
then the child goes oh oh
and that's what that is is the shame
that we feel we're being looked at and
we feel all that shame and we can't
handle it so we dump it on our child and
that's how shame gets visited down the
generations wow yeah that's explained so
well and it just like you said it's
coming out of fear we're afraid of what
people are gonna think of us they're
looking at us and so we're reacting out
of fear so what do you do in that
particular example you gave where you
explained that you wanted to do this and
and then what do you do if they still
don't want to give it back okay totally
understandable that your four-year-old
does not want to give that bucket back
or even two-year-olds or even or
two-year-old especially yeah
four-year-old's more likely to give it
back yeah yeah but but the two year old
certainly doesn't get yeah that this was
somebody else's bucket and even if they
did they don't care yeah two girls do
have empathy but they also have not
learned that they will always get their
needs met and therefore they're like I'm
gonna look out for number one I'm gonna
grab that bucket yeah so at that point
you you first of all
take that deep breath because your fear
is starting to rise that everybody's
going to look at you and think you're a
terrible Mom that's the first thing
then you say to the child in question
that because you're trying to make this
okay and keep that child from exploding
right the temperature is rising in the
room or in the playground you say to
this child
oh that's your red bucket isn't it and
he took your red bucket
you weren't done with it were you and
the child's like yeah so you've already
got that child you and that child are in
alignment the child's not going to
explode yet that's great okay and you
look at the mother or father you say I'm
so sorry we'll get it back right so that
you're connecting with so that now you
you've got a little time right you've
just bought yourself a tiny bit of time
so you know and you feel a little better
like No One's Gonna think badly of you
but you still have no idea how you're
gonna get the bucket back right the way
you're gonna get the bucket back is
you're going to start by affirming
you're going to connect with your child
you if your child feels that you have
suddenly left their corner and you're
fighting with them and trying to get
that bucket back your child is never
going to give the bucket back and you're
going to be you know unclenching their
fingers and they're screaming at the top
of their lungs right you may still have
to do that you may but you're definitely
going to have to do that if you don't
connect with your child so now that
you've bought yourself a little time you
turn to your own child and you say
that is a beautiful bucket I see why you
wanted Meanwhile your child is like not
looking at you they're filling that
bucket as fast as they canvas and
they're like I've never seen you before
in my life you know I don't know who you
are lady
and you say that is a great bucket
you're filling it with sand you wish you
could keep that bucket
and your child's like
you wish you could keep that bucket
maybe you can use it after right now
and you you give them some other options
you know right now we have the blue
bucket
or we can use the dump truck right or we
can go to the water fountain and get a
drink you can you know too many options
for a toddler doesn't work you really
can't do more than two options for a
toddler right
um but you decide what you're going to
offer is the options and Meanwhile your
toddler's still ignoring you they're
they're filling up that bucket as fast
as they can and you say you wish you
could keep the bucket I see you we need
to give the bucket back now what did I
just do I I totally empathized I
validated I connected and I set a really
clear limit and right now we need to
give the bucket back at this point a
two-year-old is going to do any number
of things depending on the two-year-old
they might
thrust thrust it back nicely that would
be great they might curl it at her head
which would not be as great
um luckily it's full of sand so they
can't get it very high
um they might say no I won't right
um you know every every kid's a little
different
um and you say you wish you could keep
it I'm gonna give you let's pork now
what I would do is I would say let's
pour
the the blue bucket that's oh look at
this said you're putting your hands on
the blue bucket your kid's got a hand on
the blue bucket too and looking at you
like and you pick up the blue Buck you
say let's pour help me pour help me pour
in your child's helping you if you have
a relationship with your child that is
about connection which is our goal and
you've just connected this way you're
saying help me pour and your child's
like uh okay and you're pouring into
their red bucket and you say look at
look at you filled it up and you put
that beautiful sand in the red bucket
and you've got the blue bucket here and
you're saying and let's ask her if you
can use the blue bucket when she's ready
when she's done we need to give it back
now and you're handing it to the mother
let's say so it's over your child's head
and your child's like
and you say you want that can we ask and
you model with you so people often say
what if my child won't say he's sorry
model it yeah what if your child doesn't
know how to ask model it you say let's
ask her when you're done with your
beautiful blue bucket do you think that
kofax could have a turn you know and and
she might go no and she grabs the bucket
you say she loves that bucket she
doesn't want to share it I understand we
all feel that way sometimes and you know
that's that and if your child is now
screaming you pick your child up and you
hug him you say it was so hard to give
that back I am so proud of you he's
screaming you're still sane I am so
proud of you that was so hard to do and
it wasn't our bucket we had to give it
back I am so proud of you it's hard to
give something back when you want it a
lot of times too though the distraction
of like what else at this age right what
else can we get excited about is enough
it's totally enough and we get sometimes
parents can get caught up in the like
okay I have to punish them because they
have to learn that they can't take away
something from somebody else and they
need discipline and punishment but
really it depends on their age as well
like at the age of two like literally
distraction is all you need most of the
time really true wow look at that
butterfly yes yes but let's talk about
what discipline is yeah people are
confused about discipline discipline is
when we decide
when we decide inside what's most
important to us and we act on it so I
want this piece of cake but there's
something I want more I want my health
that's a higher value to me I'm going to
put that Health above the cake and act
on that right and what just happened
with the two-year-old that two-year-old
wanted that bucket but he wanted
something more he wanted that connection
with you and you were connecting if you
had just said no no we have to give it
back that's not a connection your child
has nothing to substitute right yeah and
we we wonder
when children are undisciplined
when children don't act with discipline
there are two reasons one is when
they're when limits aren't set and
they're never asked to do that because
when we do this neural wiring develops
so when
if you if your child willingly gives up
that bucket or even grudgingly gives up
the bucket for something they want more
which is the relationship with you right
when he's 10 and you say it's time to
stop building with your Legos and go to
bed or whatever he's doing
he's like Mom you say I know you love
doing that and it's time to get ready
for bed right he's gonna again he's
built the neural wiring he's able to do
that when he's 14 and his buddies say
come on smoke some weed with us behind
the school he's like
really want to do that but I really
don't want to get kicked off the soccer
team I'm not I'm going to choose the
soccer team right he's developed the
neural wiring for self-discipline but
what would have happened if we just
grabbed the bucket away no neural wiring
gets built he's not actually making a
choice right so and what would happen if
we said oh sorry little girl we're gonna
use the bucket for a while okay oh you
don't mind do you right again he's not
asked to give up the bucket right if we
say oh I know you want to stay up a
little later go ahead half an hour or
whatever and we keep you know extending
the bedtime
when we don't set limits
children don't learn self-discipline
because they're never asked to give up
the thing they want for what they want
more but also when we are basically a
bully about it when we are authoritarian
about it when we're strict parents they
also don't willingly give it up because
the discipline isn't internal it's
external no go take your bath right now
right that's external discipline they're
not developing internal self-discipline
and then it more becomes about hiding
from the authority to get away with
things which is what happens when they
become teenagers exactly and you can't
you're no matter what age your child is
now you will not believe how fast the
teen years come and how they are out of
your sight and they become very good
liars if they need to no they don't have
to my kids told me pretty much what was
going on in their teen years because we
have that kind of relationship and if
you want your kids to want to come to
you in their teenagers and ask your
advice
start now by making that your
relationship a safe place I love that so
much and it reminds me of my own
childhood because I think my parents
raised me with this type of gentle
peaceful parenting without even really
knowing the term for it and I never felt
any time from my parents I always I
always went to them and kind of told
them and like we didn't even have a
curfew actually like that was just
something that just trusted us and when
I would come home late it wasn't
something to be afraid of it was like oh
my mom would say oh you were home pretty
late tonight maybe maybe next time you
should come home you know by 10 and I'm
like oh yeah okay all right you're right
sorry because we had so much trust
involved so that is a really interesting
Factor whereas other friends of mine
they were raised with a way where they
were getting in trouble all the time
very punitive and disciplined to where
when they got to that age of teenage
years they wanted to hide things and
they hid things from their parents yes
so something else you said that I really
wanted to touch on you said about
setting limits so an example when the 10
year old you say it's time for bed is
there ever room for like like the art of
negotiation sure because that's
something really I'm interested in where
kids can grow up to learn how to
advocate for what they want and
sometimes they will change my mind and I
tell that to my two oldest especially
like look I like I'm happy to change my
mind but you don't need to convince me
why why we should change your mind you
don't change the mind and you do that by
you as the parent expressing your
concern and the child learning to meet
that concern so your child wants to stay
up later but you're concerned that when
they have stayed up later in the past in
the morning they don't get up in time
for school
you know you wake them up and they're
cranky because they didn't have enough
sleep so you say
that's your concern right and so in this
case there's not really something the
child can do to get around that concern
yeah but what they can do is they can
say I know you're concerned about that
mom that that I get enough sleep
I promise that I'm gonna set no I'm not
a big fan of kids using alarms I like
them to wake up on their own but your
child might well say to you I'm gonna
set my alarm you can be just my backup
but I promise I will get myself out of
bed your child's learning
self-discipline there's something they
want more than to stay in that bed which
is in the future they want to be allowed
to stay up a little bit later right and
so they would need to negotiate that
with you so I would just say it's always
a matter of them
telling you what they want and you
saying hmm I see why you want that
here's my concern about it yeah and then
meeting that concern and if they can
meet that concern you know they're going
to have a great future in whatever
profession they choose because they'll
be able to move through roadblocks by
addressing the concerns of those around
them that's a really great skill to have
yes absolutely that's what my my eldest
is like amazing at the art of
negotiation there will be certain times
where maybe he'll ask for a play date
and then me and like my the other mom or
dad and the other one like he's trying
to organize like a triple play date and
we're like oh not today I don't think so
because somehow he'll convince all the
parents that today is the best day to do
the play date it should happen because
of this and we're like oh that is true
this is a good idea we should do it
later by the end of it we all think it's
a great day to have a play date it's
just so interesting it takes some
flexibility from the parent but I think
when we're at our best and we're present
we can be more flexible right we don't
have to win we don't have to be right we
can be more flexible and if we do feel
we're being steamrolled it's also okay
to say no it's also okay to say I hear
how much you want this I'm going to say
no because I actually don't have the
bandwidth to figure this out today but I
hear how much you want all three of you
to be able to play and I'm I hear you've
got it all figured out and I'm willing
to listen tonight right now we need to
pick the little ones up from wherever
yes so you're allowed to say no also yes
and the difference between these
scenarios we just explained of the art
of negotiation versus your first example
of how about 30 minutes more all right
30 minutes more all right 30 minutes
more all right that's the passive
parenting where it's just the okay I
don't want them to whine at me okay 30
minutes more okay and then before you
know it things are out of control right
and that's not the kind of parenting I
advocate obviously so when people say
that it's permissive parenting my kids
always said to me well Mom
we have the home where the parents are
nicest to the kids but we also how come
we always have to do the extra credit
and we don't get to eat sugar and you
know we don't get to watch TV I mean we
had a lot of expectations in our home
and a lot of limits but also the most
um nurturing environment for them do you
think that it gets harder to do this to
be this
um present and able to communicate as
well as like that example you gave with
the bucket or with the kid going to bed
is it does it get harder the more kids
you have because sometimes I'm like yes
I want to do that when that happens next
time but then I'm like I'm carrying the
brand new baby and then my other kid is
asking me to go here on the swing with
me and like trying to be present with
all five is just like difficult it is
difficult so does it do you feel like it
gets harder the more kids you have and
what are your thoughts on that well
first of all yes because you've only got
so much bandwidth you've got the baby
crying and you've got the two-year-old
into something and you've got the
five-year-old asking you for something
you know think of like a really good
preschool teacher you know and she's got
her hand on one kid and she's talking to
another child and she looks up at over
the kid's shoulder and says Ah Eric you
know so she's you can do that to some
degree but it takes a lot of focus and
presence and you're worn out at the end
of the day and that's only three right
so you know if you've got five it's that
much harder yes on the other hand
I would say you get better at parenting
I think we are all we visit our greatest
Neurosis on the oldest child we visit
all of our hopes and fears and
expectations and all the places that we
are not fully worked out the Kinks
inside ourselves our own psyches that
gets visited on your first child usually
so the first child usually has a harder
time actually so by the time you get
your fifth child you're so much more
relaxed and your child doesn't think
it's an emergency life is an emergency
your child's like yeah mom's pretty
relaxed about this I think things are
good or you know and also they're
entertained by the older children
absolutely right they're designed to be
influenced by other children babies and
toddlers And at each stage of
development children are designed to be
influenced by kids their age and a
little older whereas we just seem like a
whole different thing to them right yeah
yeah you know so that's also a great
thing about having more kids and then
the final thing I would say is that when
you have a big family and you've
parented this way your children are
likely to be more nurturing they won't
be perfect any more than we are but
they're likely to be more nurturing and
big families have to depend on the
children to parent each other a little
bit it's not an appropriate role for
them to be the parents true they they
can't be they have their own
developmental needs but it is certainly
fine for the six-year-old to say to the
two-year-old when you know when you're
trying to deal with a new baby and the
baby's crying and the two-year-olds
for the six-year-old to say oh your your
food fell on the ground oh let me help
you we can do that we can fix this
because someone did that for the
six-year-old ones so I do think they
have
a much more complicated web of
relationships and they sometimes feel
like they don't get enough parental
attention sometimes so you have to
really work at that to connect with each
child but on the other hand they have
the richness of all of the other
siblings both the older ones and the
younger ones
um you know I was the oldest daughter
and we had you know my parents were
divorced and both had more children and
so I think I learned to parent partly
through my through being with my younger
sibs and that's a great gift yes I
definitely find that to be true for sure
my older ones are helping me so much
yeah it would be way too hard if I
didn't have their help they're helping
all the time and they want to help
because they see the way that their dad
and their mom like love on the little
ones and so they love loving on the
little ones too and they come look see
what see what dagne's doing and they
just love to play with them together and
be helpful so that's absolutely true and
I know from that description that they
feel loved enough because if they didn't
if they felt like like they weren't
getting what they needed or they were
somehow being
judged for their desire to be close to
you or to get loving from you if that
were happening they would not be able to
love on the baby
but they're getting the love they need
oh that's good to know that's really
helpful okay so let's get into sibling
rivalry a little bit what causes sibling
rivalry that is that is a big thing for
us and our family and all of my friends
I think it's a great segue because
sibling rivalry is a natural part of
having humans who are in competition for
the same scarce resource and the
resources in fact parental attention now
it may not be scarce actually there may
be plenty of love to go around but if we
are expressing that love through eye
contact and hugs and warm moments
together snuggling where they get full
attention that can be harder to come by
in a larger family or even honestly in a
family with two kids when I've seen so
many families with two children where
the oldest has never forgiven the
younger one for being born and it's
partly because when the baby's born the
older kid looks so big looks so big and
you think
you're a giant you don't need me anymore
right be quiet stop waking the baby be
nice to the baby you know we're we have
this attitude of
um
you need too much toward the oldest
child and so they don't forgive the baby
for being born right I think
we can you can't get rid of sibling
rivalry but you can mitigate it by
accepting everyone's needs even your
oldest sometimes needs to be babied
right we all sometimes need to be babied
even grown-ups right so if we can meet
their needs you can reduce the sibling
rivalry that's one thing another cause
of sibling rivalry is just difference in
what each person wants out of the
interaction and in every human
relationship there will be different
needs different wants so hopefully with
our partners spouses we can express what
we need and want without attacking them
you know like
I hate it when you've always got the
music blaring is sort of an attack you
know whereas I really love quiet I love
when I'm waking up in the morning to
have quiet and you've got the news on
and it just feels I I can't quite cope
yet that's more of a expressing my needs
rather than attacking my partner right
most of us adults don't remember that
there are many times we make the mistake
of expressing our needs as an attack so
we can assume children will do the same
thing we have to work on that we have to
work on modeling it and we have to help
our children when when one of the kids
says to the other
why are you always singing and humming I
just want to focus on what I'm doing and
we can say it's hard for you when your
sister is always singing and humming and
you love to sing at home and I love to
hear you hum and sing but your sister
really wants to focus on what she's
doing how can we work this out you're
not making anyone bad and wrong they
have different needs so one way to ease
sibling rivalry is when the children
know that their needs will be taken
seriously and that you will help them to
navigate that difference in needs so
that they can each get their needs met
and there are ways to do it and I've
seen many solutions to that particular
thing like on even days you can sing and
on odd days you can't was one family's
thing that they came up with and they
did it for years with those girls and it
worked for the girls the girls came up
with it and it worked so that's fine
that's hilarious and and the older one
who was the one who was annoyed stop
being so perpetually anointed her sister
because at least she knew that on even
days it was quiet or whatever yes yeah
okay so what about specifically when the
older someone can often get the blame
for things so let's say they're like
older kids because we did a couple
examples for like toddlers but older
kids that are just arguing a lot and a
lot of times it's instigated by the
older one and maybe it's a Personality
Clash could it sometimes be that and
maybe it's the competition thing or
modeled behavior from their parents how
do we navigate that when let's say a
specific example your older brother
starts attacking the younger one for who
knows what they took the Nerf gun they
took the Nerf gun or or maybe the older
one was was shooting the Nerf gun at the
younger one the younger one said stop it
I don't want stop it no stop stop I'm
not playing stop and he kept going kept
going until he hit him in the face and
it really hurt and then there's a huge
whale and then they attack each other
okay so let's use that example of the
Nerf gun and he can't gets it in the
face what does every single parent do in
that moment
they get mad at the older kids yes yeah
they come running into the situation
screening at the top of their lungs Nemo
they've got a crying childhood they're
not even taking care of they're
screaming at the top of their looks you
know better you're the Big Brother you
heard him say stop so what are the
takeaways from each child hmm takeaways
I think from the younger child is the
latter I scream the more mad the parents
get at the older brother yeah that's
also one and maybe also that the older
brother gets attention but even though
it's negative attention yeah from the
appearance
um the older one
oh I don't know but for the younger one
also that like no matter how they acted
in the moment it's not their fault
because the older brother yes good and
they might have been taunting the older
brother before this we don't know what
happened we can't we're not omniscient
yeah and even if you were watching out
the kitchen window and you know exactly
what happened in that moment you don't
know what happened an hour ago or
yesterday yes the build up to this right
yeah yeah
um and the older ones takeaway is
mom always takes his side yeah yeah
she's his faith he's he's her favorite
um she never understands me it wasn't my
fault you just wait till I get him alone
my whole life has been bad ever since he
was born and it's all his fault yeah
right he he's angry have we just helped
our children get along better in the
future no no and you notice what
happened is that we made it worse by the
way we came into the situation now
imagine that instead
we were had just listened to this
podcast and we were able to take even as
we're running to the sound of the
yelling the crying
we're taking a breath and we're saying
we're saying to ourselves
I can manage this it doesn't mean my
older child is going to be a serial
killer and it doesn't mean they're never
going to get along it's going to be okay
easy I don't should take anyone to the
hospital it's going to be you know
whatever we need to say to calm
ourselves down in that moment
we we come out we ignore the perpetrator
completely ignore the older child and go
immediately to the child who's crying
and he's like and he's got a big red
spot on his cheek where the Nerf gun hit
him and you put your arms around me say
oh that really hurts huh oh now the
older Michelle's watching this
and you're completely ignoring it but if
you're calm enough you can take this up
a notch you can say
quick
whatever your kid's name is Cody get an
ice pack yeah right if you can do that
if you can do it nicely yeah yeah you've
just given Cody the older child the
opportunity to come back into the
community of the family again really a
helper instead of a herder yeah right
he's redeemed himself but maybe you
can't even do that because you're just
mad yeah yeah so you just take care of
the little one and you're like oh that
really heard out let's go get you an ice
pack let's go get you a warm a wet
washcloth whatever and you take care of
him and you come and you let him tell
you all you're taking him away from his
brother you're not like making rubbing
the brother's nose in it you're just
helping the younger child calm down and
he tells you all about it because that's
part of calming down I told him to stop
and he wouldn't stop it and you say to
him it sounds like you have something
really yes you're right our family rule
is stop means stop this is a basic rule
in any human relationship it's the
foundation of all consent very important
that kids learn stop mean stop and it's
not unusual for the older sibling or the
younger sibling to not listen to that
and we need to reinforce it it doesn't
mean your child's going to be a bad
person it means we need to reinforce
that rule that limit but we listen to
the younger child and we say and you
said stop and he didn't stop
ouch that makes you so sad and mad you
felt so bad when he did that your heart
it hurts your face and it also hurts
your heart I think you know it sounds to
me like you have something you need to
tell your brother
once your child is calm you take them to
do it but right now you say I'll help
you when you're ready
and you say once we fix once your face
feels better and we take some deep
breaths
then you'll be strong and rooted in the
ground and you'll be able to go and tell
your brother what you need right so
we're not going to just fly off in a
rage to tell the brother so we've we've
helped him and if the child who's not
you know who got hurt is has a type of
personality that's more quiet and Inward
and just may never really want to like
say it outwardly do you do that for them
with them yes you do it for them and
with them you you help them do it but
right now they're her so they are
telling you and you say you you're
notice I was really putting it I was
saying your heart must have hurt too
right because yeah Joe doesn't know how
to say that it that was a betrayal when
they said stop and they got hit in the
face right so you say you said stop and
then he didn't stop right and then hit
you in the face you're articulating it
so he knows yeah what happened was wrong
and and I said stop and that should have
been respected I had a right to expect
to to be listened to so we're helping
that quiet child develop the ability to
stand up for himself off simply by
acknowledging what happened to him and
that now he sounds like he feels really
upset about it and he wants to to tell
us he has not he wants to because he he
both wants to he doesn't want to he
adores his big brother he idolizes him
he wants to play with him Big Brother
barely plays with him he wants to let
make him play with you know there's all
kinds of complicated feelings so I
wouldn't say he wants to tell him the
quiet child I would say it sounds like
you have something really important to
tell your brother that you didn't like
it when you said stop and he didn't stop
and he's like I didn't like it so we're
gonna tell your brother
yeah I can't and you say I will help you
I will help you and when he's ready
you might even say let's take a break
first so we calm down first what would
you like to do now maybe he plays with
his little figurines to calm himself
down and you say let's set you up with
your figurines you can have a few
minutes just to play and I'm gonna go
talk with your brother and you set him
up and you go to the brother because you
want to soften the brother a little bit
because if he sees you coming with a
little one he's going to think okay now
it comes she sides with a little one
right yeah so you want it you want to
get him set up with something so he can
play for a little bit and calm down
and and you've just given him probably
15 minutes you've given him a little
time now if you have a baby this is a
little harder right because you've got
so many things going on but you can have
the baby on your hip while you do this
yeah and you go to the older child who
did this
and you say wow that was hard huh notice
I didn't say you're bad you're wrong you
didn't stop say that was hard now he's
acting like he's never seen you before
doing whatever he's doing he's saying
your brother was really crying
he had a red mark on his cheek you're
just describing what happened you're now
you could say you're guilting him you're
shaming him but notice it's a pretty
matter-of-fact voice but you're
describing what happened and you say
when you when you were shooting at him
you know our rule is that we don't shoot
at the face
right and he's like yeah you say
um and you know a rule is we say we we
stop you know he's like yeah say You
must have been pretty upset to keep
shooting
in that moment it must have been so hard
it was hard for you to stop you kept
shooting and you shot him in the face I
didn't mean to hit his face he was
moving
oh I'm glad you didn't mean to hit his
face you just take that face out you
don't say you're lying to me you say you
say I'm glad you didn't mean to hit his
face because our family rule is this
because you know if it hits your eye it
could be really serious you know that so
so I'm really glad you didn't mean to
his face and I know if he's moving is
hard
and it must have been really hard for
you to stop because he was saying stop
and it was hard for you to stop shooting
at him
and he doesn't know what to say at this
point because he doesn't really know why
he couldn't stop and you say sometimes
it's hard to stop when we're when we're
doing something that we want to do
it sounds like that was really hard for
you do you remember what happened
and he's like
yeah I mean he's still you know yeah and
you're you say
um I know you love your brother and I
know you must have had some other
feelings going on like maybe you were
mad at him
or maybe
I don't know what other thing there
could be I was trying to do something a
little more innocuous right yeah
sometimes it's like I just wanted to bug
him uh-huh yes maybe you were mad at him
because you know before he wouldn't
listen to you whatever
um and then usually as you acknowledge
what might be true for him there's
usually a point a Tipping Point where
instead of um
he goes
yes you know what ah you know I wanted
to bug him here's why he never blah he
always blood you know whatever it is and
it spills out and parents are like
I cannot believe this I've raised a
monster no this is good news that it's
out instead of in remember if he
articulates it he doesn't have to act on
it
we want to prevent this from happening
in the future and as he spills out all
the stuff you say wow wow oh I hear you
it's so frustrating for you when he
always it's so upsetting to you when he
never you just you don't even have to
agree with him you're acknowledging how
he feels that's totally appropriate
and he unloads and he unloads and he
unloads and you acknowledge and
acknowledge and acknowledge
and at some point he's done and he's
sort of shocked that you're not that
you're listening and that you're not
blaming blame not blaming him exactly
and he's like hopeful like maybe you do
understand them a little bit maybe
somebody is in his corner and he's like
yeah you're like wow maybe I I have a
parent who cares what matters to me
right even though I was terrible yeah
they know even though I was terrible and
did this thing and so he spills all this
to you and you're like oh oh I hear you
I hear you I hear you and then he comes
to a point where he stops and you give
him a hug you haven't said anything like
you're bad and wrong and did the bat
wrong thing you're you have said what
your family rules are right and you
might not even have said that yet you he
might have just started to offload right
away right
um so you give him a hug you're not done
yet but you're giving him a hug and you
say I am so sorry this has been so hard
for you I want you to know that you
don't have to keep this all inside when
you feel like this about your brother
you can always come and tell me and I
will always understand sometimes it's
hard to be the big brother right you're
just you're you're validating
everything and you're making your
relationship safe for him to come to you
for help and articulate so he doesn't
have to act it out on his brother right
I just wanted to annoy him by shooting
him when he said no right yeah and then
you so you've given him a hug you've
said this and he's like what I have seen
happen is I I remember with my own son
when he was little and his sister was
born and I would say it's so hard for
you when she's on my lap and nursing all
the time and you just want me to come
and help you with your trains or
whatever he would he would he would
start from a place of like
I hate her and then he would
you know I would give him the hug and he
would just sort of melt in my arms just
melt and then he wouldn't necessarily
say anything but he would go over to her
maybe not even right then maybe he'd go
play with his trains but a half an hour
later I'd see him go over to where she
was sleeping and pet her gently
when we allow all of the ugly feelings
ugly in quotes to come out
then all the love that's in there can
has room to surface right and the child
can feel it if they've got all that ugly
stuff inside and no safe place to take
it that's gonna control their behavior
so notice there's still one piece we
haven't done
we hugged him and he's melted in our
arms
and he's taking a deep breath like yes I
have my parent and they understand and
then we say
I I you reaffirm that you understand and
you say and when someone says no we have
to stop what we're doing no means no you
know that's our that's one of our most
important family Rules and he's like I
know and you say
I know you know
and sometimes in the future it's still
going to be hard for you
next time this happens that you feel
like that he says stop and you feel like
it's too hard to stop what could you do
instead
and then you help him come up with a
scenario like you might even say here
here's the here's the teddy bear the
teddy bear is is your brother and it's
saying no no and you've got the Nerf gun
and you want to keep shooting it what do
you do
and he maybe he says I could turn and
shoot it over there you say yes because
it's always easier to redirect the
impulse than to stop an Impulse always
right so that's an example of what he
might do or he might say I could shoot
in the air or he might say I could say
to him
and you might come up with something
mean to say to his brother like you're
such a coward and at that point let's
say it's a bad thing he comes up with
you say hmm well that would make you not
not make you stop shooting he said yeah
but I would still get to say you know
can you say so those mean feelings would
still come out huh
I wonder what would happen then this is
how we help children develop good
judgment you could do that I wonder what
would happen then yeah it would still be
an attack it would still be hurtful to
the brother hmm
and is that what you would really want
to do
no okay so let's come up with something
different maybe you're going to move the
Nerf gun but the point is and you can
come and what if you still have those
mean feelings inside you what are you
going to do then you can come and talk
to me come and talk to me and or scream
Mom I need your help you know and I will
if I can grab the baby and come I can't
always come but you sometimes I'll say
come to me and you and you I will always
be there as your Lifeline right
I just think we
um
we ignore these opportunities to help
our children repeat this in the future
if you did this you're not going to have
that Nerf gun incident again right and
parents I know I know the parents
listening and watching are going to say
I don't have time for that yeah I I are
you kidding me I know I was just gonna
bring that up the answer is it takes
three months the answer is that I've
been doing this for many years and I've
watched many thousands of parents do
this and it gets better every day
because as you rewire your own brain
they're rewiring their brains and they
become more able to manage themselves
right but also
over a three-month period that's a very
short time in a child's life even a 10
year olds they learn how to do something
different and you'll start to hear
something where the kid will say stop
and the other kid will say oh I'm not
going to play with you anymore and toss
down the Nerf gun and go and the younger
will come running and say he won't play
with me and you can say oh you're so
disappointed but you know what he didn't
do he didn't shoot it at you anymore I
heard you say stop and he stopped good
for you for sticking up for yourself
give me five right yeah I love the way
that you broke that down that's so so
helpful and it's applicable to
everything with siblings and I think for
anyone listening who's like okay I don't
have time for this or no that's coddling
the kid that's gonna spend too much time
coddling and then you're gonna raise
whatever coddling part I don't know
because I don't see how that's coddling
we didn't shame and blame the older
child right instead we said you know the
rule yes and it sounds like it was
really hard for you and you can't break
that rule so what are we going to do
differently next time we taught the
child how to manage themselves so true
that's what we want to be different do
we need to make him wrong and bad to do
that absolutely is that if you're at
your workplace and you have a boss and
you mess up the equivalent like you knew
you shouldn't have done that thing point
the Nerf gun whatever it is in your
office and you did it anyway and your
boss comes to you and says shames and
blames you is that going to make you do
a better job next time no when we have
shame and blame inside us we act badly
yes and your son will also or daughter
will also act badly if there's shame and
blame him I know and I think when people
try to say that whatever you just
described it's coddling or it's whatever
the word that they attach to it they
have this fear that they're going to
grow up and be this like I don't know
entitled person but I think what they're
forgetting is that when when we do the
parenting the strict parenting the
example you gave where you just come
attack shut down the emotions then we
have so this is why we have so many
adults walking around that don't know
how to regulate their emotions yes I
don't know how to how to express even
what they're feeling especially boys but
it could be boys or girls yeah but a lot
of times boys grow up and and then they
get in a relationship and the partner's
like why can't you communicate with me
like let's talk and they're like I I
don't know even how to say it right
because of what how they're being raised
was yeah yeah we we don't want to raise
people who never get angry that would be
impossible we want to raise people who
notice when they're getting angry back
when it's annoyance or frustration
before it gets to be rage right we want
to help us help our children notice and
put it into words and Advance their own
needs in a respectful way that doesn't
dump on other people right every you
know we girls and boys we want them to
stick up for what they want and need in
a way that is appropriate yeah yeah and
healthy communication and yet for some
reason I think people assume that as
adults we're supposed to be this like
stoic like we don't have we don't have
to express ourselves in a certain way
that makes us strong but really that
doesn't a lot of times that creates so
much havoc in actual relationships
because then they don't know how to
communicate well because problems always
arrives there are going to be problems
in life and we need to be able to
communicate well to get through them
healthfully yeah yeah wow that's amazing
and so is there a point is there any
kind of requirement in that scenario
where the older child has to say sorry
yes I'm so glad that you mentioned that
because we didn't get to that so once
you've gone through this with your child
you then say you know
your brother
he he had this big red mark on his cheek
it's probably faded now he's fine
sweetheart you know you make sure to say
that and you touch your child you know
you're connecting and you say
and his heart was hurt that he said stop
and you didn't stop you didn't hear him
you didn't respond to what he asked and
he felt a little betrayed I think that
his brother who loves him his big
brother
um didn't listen and and did something
that hurt him he he needs to be able to
tell you that and he's like
you know but you've just understood him
and he knows what he did was not okay
and you say let's go find your brother
and by now his brother is happily
playing with whatever and you go over
and you you touch both children you
don't just ditch your older child
because he'll feel like okay she
listened to me but now she's on his side
again right you keep touching him and
you also are touching your younger child
and you say we have two boys here who
love each other so much two brothers
here love each other so much and
sometimes they have to work things out
sometimes they're hurt feelings
sometimes they're hurt bodies you have
something you want to tell your brother
and maybe he's the quiet kid who
wouldn't tell his brother and you say do
you remember if you're going to tell
your brother and he's like
don't hurt me you know he doesn't know
what to say and you say don't hurt you
and also when you say stop you want him
to hear you right so you help him do it
and he says yeah when I say stop stop
right stop you might even say stop you
know he might have a stop you know he
might be not sure how tough to be in
this you know and the older child's like
okay right and you say so we need to
make things better we need to make a
repair you're not going to mandate
okay you lose your screen time for a
week or whatever you're not going to do
that you're going to say to your to the
child
I wonder what you could do to make
things better with your brother
and you know if if there's still a red
mark on his cheek he could do something
like that and and he can also say
I mean maybe he won't have any ideas if
you if you're just beginning this he
wouldn't have any ideas if you've done
this a few times he's going to say we
could play Nerf guns and we could
practice you saying stop and I will
always stop which would be an amazing
repair a corrective repair where the
younger child would feel heard that'd be
great if that was what they decided or
he could say I would help you with the
thing you wanted help with teaching you
to throw a ball or whatever it was he
was gonna you know that he wanted I'd
let you play with me while I do XYZ
could be anything
if both kids feel okay about it your job
as the parent is to accept it but if if
it's something that you think is really
not very much of a repair like like say
he's like I'm sorry yeah you could say
then first of all you make a mental note
I did not do enough work with this child
he's not actually expressing sorryness
so I need to listen to him more it's a
it's a big chip on the shoulder he's
carrying around we need to melt that a
little bit over time so is that I'm
guessing that's not a place to be like
well that's not a good enough sorry oh I
would ask I would ask the other child I
would say so your brother said he was
sorry
did you feel like that makes things
better
and
many children will say no he said sorry
right many children will say that some
kids would be like yeah yeah and you
could say it sounds like you don't
really think that made things better if
he's just sort of hesitating and you can
and you can say you can say that to your
brother we're always coaching them to
speak for themselves if they can and
when they can't we step in so he might
say the younger child might say you're
not really sorry and and the older child
looks and you say and you you remember
you're touching both you might even put
your arm around and give them a hug even
if you have to let go of the little one
for a minute and you're and you say it's
hard to apologize it's hard to apologize
and
your brother loves you and I know you
love him and even though that was really
hard and you feel bad about it what
happened
it's you need to make it better is that
something you can do right now or do you
want to wait until like my daughter used
to say to me I can't apologize when I'm
mad you're asking me to lie but I can do
it later and that was our deal that she
was allowed to do it when she was ready
as long as it was before the next meal
yeah right they can't go to bed I mean
if there's if it's gonna be before
breakfast it's like they have to do it
before bedtime right yeah but but maybe
he's like all right I'm sorry and you
can say does that feel better now okay
hug it out yeah and after after they
both feel like it's a decent enough
um repair then you can say okay you
ready to hug it out because I find that
when kids hug it out they always end up
laughing yes oh that's so good and do
you ever find that there's a place to
say oh go to your rooms together and
work it out on your own
um I think that we
um were told to do that instead of
intervening my mom told me yeah I've
even talked about this on this podcast
that sometimes that that is what I do
and I'm like you know what you guys work
it out together so so we what happened
is that um somewhere along the line I
think
um we were told that it when we
intervene by coming in and screaming and
saying it's all your fault and making
one of the kids wrong it worsensed
sibling rivalry no question we know that
from the research so parents were
advised to let the kids Work It Out
themselves and what we found out is that
if the parents just like she's at the
kitchen sink or she's working at her
computer and the kids are screaming at
each other and working it out themselves
and they did a lot of filming of this
and what they learned is that this the
child who is the strongest child wins it
is usually the older child but sometimes
it's a younger child sometimes it's the
one who's willing to make the most noise
so that could be a younger child to
finally get the parent involved right
but usually what happens is if the
parent is I'm not going to get involved
I'm letting them work it out they're
going to learn how to do this what they
learn is not you know we just taught
them so many skills right no that's not
what they're learning they're learning
if they bully the other child they win
and that's what they do so we're
teaching bullying and when you ask the
children you've been filming this right
you're the researcher you ask the
children they'll say
mom and dad think it's okay that he
treats me that way and threatens to hit
me because she was right there at her
computer and she didn't intervene now
maybe you didn't hear it no but they
take it if you're in the house it's a
tacit endorsement of the behavior yes so
that's a terrible thing to teach them
yes now I will say it's not always a
terrible thing to have them work it out
but first we have to do what I've been
describing yeah first we have to teach
them the skills then
after we've taught them the skills if
let's say they're roughly equal in power
you know you've got a nine-year-old and
11 year old a nine year old is pretty
good at sticking up for herself let's
say yeah um and they're fighting about I
don't know
um which movie to watch you do not have
to now if if they've if they know that
basically they have the skills you do
not have to help them figure out which
movie to watch you can say okay well you
know Saturday night is movie night and
you can watch you know any of the movies
on this list or whatever they know what
they can choose from
um and you two get to decide
um and I hear that you want to watch
this movie and she wants to watch and
you want to watch this movie that's a
hard decision maybe one of you will
convince the other or maybe you'll
decide on a third movie you want to
watch but that's up to the two of you of
course go off and you do not need to be
in the middle of that that's good for
them to get the skills right yeah I feel
like we've done like a little bit of
half and half of what you're talking
about like those that example you gave
of connecting them like we have
foundational principles of that and then
there are certain times when if we are
too busy that is part of it or if it's
like feels sometimes like oh maybe
sometimes there's a fear I think of oh
if I give the the one who's screaming
too much attention that they're going to
want to scream more like that that that
oh they're screaming louder and louder
to her now I can't tell the difference
between a Nerf gun in the face or the
child's actually falling off a cliff you
know what I'm saying and and so it
there's that that type of fear as well
sometimes I think with parents are like
okay I think I need to let them work it
out themselves and not be the one that's
but not not picking sides but your
example doesn't pick sides yes so you're
never picking sides yeah with my example
I think that's the most important thing
because when we pick sides yeah even if
we don't mean to be picking sides when
they experience it as picking sides the
one who experiences not being picked
always feels like they're not as loved
and I do this I do this in front of
audiences I'll bring up two people from
the audience and I have them fight with
each other as siblings people who don't
know each other yeah yeah and then I
intervene in different in both ways and
demonstrate for the audience so when I
intervene as making one person bad and
wrong they always say the same thing
they say you don't love me as much and
the other one is like I won I won and
not only that they'll sometimes say and
this is borne out by the research
I have to keep my sibling down I have to
keep
complaining about how my sibling does
these things and and crying and whining
and escalate my upset to show how my
sibling is bad and wrong because I like
to be the favorite and this makes me the
favorite who always wins or maybe they
can't even articulate that but that is
kind of the underlying the pin so it
just shows how important it is to not
pick sides it always makes the sibling
rivalry worse so when you said what
causes sibling rivalry and I said well
competing for scarce resources
difference in needs the third reason is
the parents the parents create the
sibling rivalry by picking sides oh that
is so so helpful do you have any other
tips then for sibling rivalry as we're
listening in this is there any other
important takeaways yes the research I
feel like I have a whole book on it I do
have a whole book on it peaceful parent
happy siblings how to stop the fighting
and raise friends for life that's the
book but I will say the research is very
clear that I as the parent influence the
sibling relationship not just by the way
I discipline we talked about that
research but also by my closeness with
each
when each child feels like yeah my mom
my dad they're in my corner they adore
me no matter how much my siblings get
there's enough for me more than enough
for me when your child feels that why
would they feel sibling rivalry right
and I think that's a tall order for
parents right but we want each of our
children to feel that way we want to
find I once talked to a man who had had
10 children in his family and I said how
did you feel like did you feel like
there was enough love to go around and
he said well there were certainly times
when my mom was busy with the other kids
but she always found time to connect
with me every single day she would do
something she would like come over and
and put her arm around me and say hey
come here to the window for a minute and
look out of the stars together or you
know she would you know at the dinner
table she would give me she would say I
know you love mashed potatoes I'm going
to give you a little extra and the other
kids would be like I want extra to say
there's plenty of mashed potatoes for
everybody give me your plates you know
so I think that attitude of there's more
than enough love to go around and I'm
gonna find Opportunities to just just to
walk by my kid when they're at the easel
and say oh you're using a lot of red
today I see you're acknowledging your
child because I think the danger when
you have a lot of kids is that they
don't feel seen so just come and look at
the stars with me or I see you're using
a lot of red or I know you love mashed
potatoes you're seeing who your child is
and I think that's what matters and when
children feel seen they don't have to
Elbow other people out of the way to get
seen oh so good this is so inspiring and
I know that Andrea are going to go back
and re-listen to this for sure together
we find it really helpful to like get
that specific scenario advice and that's
you're so good at that so I I want to
move on to kind of the last final piece
of like an important part I think for
this conversation is you have an article
on your website about the secret to
saying no and why what is the deal with
that like why is it I can't get my child
to listen my no is not my no I have to
resort to counting to One Two Three or
else or threats or what else so let's
let's say you talk about that we're back
to setting limits and I think think that
so often parents who are drawn to this
kind of parenting aren't very good at
setting limits they don't know how to do
it and they are afraid to do it so I
think it all starts as it always does
inside us we have to look at
well what's keeping me from saying no
what am I afraid of well I'm afraid my
child will be mad at me
like my parents were always ready to
withdraw their love so maybe my child
will withdraw their love I mean that
happens for a lot of parents and I think
we need to take that deep breath and we
need to re-parent ourselves we need to
say it's okay for you to yourself it's
okay for you to set your limits to say
no your child loves you they know you're
the parent they're not going anywhere
parents are worried about their
children's lack of affection you know
will not be affectionate but as long as
you work on that Bond as long as
everything's through the frame of we can
be closer you know we can be connected
you can still say no in that context
right I mean let's say again we'll take
it into another relationship let's say
you and your partner have a difference
of opinion because your partner wants
you to be you know wants you to say yes
to something that you really don't feel
like you can say yes to you're allowed
to say no and you can still be just as
close to your partner right we we know
instinctively if you have a good
relationship you know they're like like
you know my husband loves to work in the
tool shop with his power tools I have
zero interest in being in the garage
with the power tools and but I will go
out and I'll admire what he does he
doesn't need to show me how to use his
circular saw I have no interest right he
was originally going let me show you how
to use a circular saw and I was like I
know you love it so much and I'm not
going to do that right I'll I'll come in
and also I never learned to play tennis
which he loves so I'm allowed to say no
to him right and we can still have a
good relationship we can go hiking
together we can share other things
together not those two things he loves
right as an example well with my child I
can say no to things my child wants and
we can still have a close relationship I
think that's the internal work we have
to do to say we can do that that's the
first thing what people say no okay and
there's there's also I think another
fear too of when you go into this type
of parenting like okay the goal is no
screaming no like outbursts and so I
gotta say yes so there's not the
Outburst all right wait a minute we're
the ones who aren't supposed to scream
it's not that the child's not allowed to
swim yeah or not we we when we scream
we're making the child unsafe so their
brain and nervous system become reactive
right we don't want that and when we
scream we're teaching them that that's a
good way to solve problems if that's
what adults do to solve problems we
don't want that is the child not allowed
to scream of course the child's allowed
to scream your child has an immature
brain and everything's an emergency to
them when someone takes their bucket or
whatever it's an emergency when you say
no cookie before dinner it's an
emergency to them right they're going to
scream and parents will say I don't know
why he does that I never hit him why is
he hitting his little sister because
it's an emergency to him that his little
sister took his toy right because his
brain is still developing exactly
exactly so there's nothing
when I say peaceful I'm describing your
own heart your child is not going to be
peaceful your child it's peaceful parent
happy kid yeah right the child is going
to end up happy because they're going to
be emotionally healthy they're allowed
to scream that's not Behavior they're
not allowed to hit they're allowed to
say they're not allowed to throw their
juice up in your face they're they might
do it when I say they're not allowed to
you want it to not repeat right it's
like whoa whoa ouch
you threw your cup you were so mad at me
right no throwing you can tell me no
mommy you know whatever right you help
them with the words so they don't have
to throw the cup but they will always
start out screaming and when a child
screams we need to listen to what why do
they need to escalate to screaming you
know kids go you've probably noticed
this kids go through the stage at around
12 months 13 months where they can't put
much into words almost nothing but they
desperately want some they reach for
something on the counter they want their
juice cup it's on the counter and
they're like reaching for it right and
if they think no help is forthcoming
they will escalate and be screaming in
the most unbearable high-pitched whale
like that and the more they learn that
you say oh that's your juice cup you
don't have to scream you can say cup
please here's your cup sweetie right and
your child learns over time they learn
to say cup please and not scream right
that's how we stop our kid from
screaming we help them see how to
advance their needs in a different way
period so screaming is natural for kids
it's often they're not allowed to scream
it's that our screaming is
counterproductive yes so you said how do
you say no I say you start inside
yourself to look at what you're afraid
of
and then you get clarity about what
matters to you and like no
um you know I always always used to say
bedtime is bedtime we're not navigating
a new bedtime every night it's like this
is what we expect this is the routine
when you have routines in your family
kids stop challenging they don't have to
fight with you about brushing teeth
because that's the routine and they may
not like it no one likes to brush their
teeth when they're you know no one
probably likes to brush their teeth I
mean maybe by adulthood but the point is
if it's part of the routine they won't
fight you about it every night I've
definitely found that to be true as soon
as we implemented this like amazing
chore chart responsibility chart they
knew exactly what was coming every day
it no longer became a fight yeah it used
to be like they were at the will of us
like oh what's happening next what do we
have to do next and then we're like oh
my gosh we need a reboot they're at an
age now where they can do schedules we
wrote it all down got them their own
chore charts with their own names on it
and now they know what's coming and they
do not argue about it they go okay yep
time to do this time to this because
it's like learning responsibility yeah
so once you have that Clarity inside
yourself about what you're gonna expect
then you just say when they say but I
want that cookie before and you say no
no cookies before dinner but you also
say You must be so hungry it's hard to
wait for dinner you know what I've got a
carrot stick no no carrot I want a
cookie
you have a choice carrot or milk you
could have a glass of milk whatever
something that will give them maybe they
don't drink milk but something that will
give them a little a little um Choice
yes exactly a little choice and fill
their belly up a little bit
um so that they can wait for dinner and
you can still hold your no and let's say
your child throws themselves down on the
floor and screams it probably wasn't
about the cookie it was probably that
they had a hard long day and they're
little and they just need to let out
some of this emotion and you say and
this is your busy time of day right and
you've got everybody's you know that's
why they call it arsenic hour right
um and you you've got you know you might
turn off what's on the stove for a
moment well you go down on the floor and
you say oh it's so hard for you when you
want a cookie and you can't have one and
you're so hungry before dinner it's okay
to cry and some parents think that's
coddling them giving in but what's that
child supposed to do with all those
feelings right oh my gosh I know this is
like the most the biggest piece to me
when people people think that that's
coddling I'm like in any adult
relationship just having someone
acknowledge your feelings no matter what
the feelings are makes it better yeah it
just does and that's for kids too yeah
and if you're having a hard time as an
adult let's say something happens and
you're upset about it and you
burst into tears maybe you even throw
your glass you know whatever you're so
upset that would be a pretty extreme
reaction if something just happened yeah
if the other adult in the room said you
go to your room and calm down and you
know when you can behave yourself you
know or what is wrong with you yes yes
you're being ridiculous like all those
things this would only be in response to
something really big obviously but even
bursting into tears that something
happened that is of magnitude to you and
when you feel understood
you will respond differently so that
toddler who's crying on the floor you
know the tears have stress hormones
ex some of the stress of the day is
coming out in the tears and actually
being expelled from the body and after
that good cry
that child is going to feel better
always yeah yeah as we all do after a
good cry yes and especially if someone's
there just like letting you feel your
feelings and acknowledging them yes yes
if you're if your child's on the floor
and you're like
and you that they're not going to feel
better because no one's holding the
space for them to have the feelings
they're just feeling shamed and they're
gonna like
pull themselves to sitting and be trying
not to cry because mommy's making that
sound cheat that she doesn't like me
when I do this whereas if you can say
you're having such a hard time I do need
to you know stir the vegetables yeah but
I'll come back and check on you in just
a minute yeah uh you know then your
child knows it's okay for them to cry
and you're coming back and forth yep and
so many of these examples go back to
just like being in a rush in life too
like you're stressed you're in a rush
and like you said like if you have
multiple kids so an earlier example you
gave were like oh the mom took the kid
outside and locked the door it reminds
me of like maybe another scenario that
could happen where maybe the mom's
really busy and they're cooking and they
have a newborn that's maybe crying and
trying to attend to both those things
and then you have two older siblings
that are fighting and one's like pulling
hair or something as a parent might be
tempted to go oh oh you know something
because they feel like they can't handle
it all at once and I don't know it just
makes me think of how stressed life is
sometimes when you're in such a rush for
everything yeah like maybe dinner can
wait maybe we can let dinner be 30
minutes later tonight maybe and and
again you can put some hummus and carrot
sticks out on the on the low table for
the kids so they're it takes a little of
the edge off their hunger because
they're always hungry at that time of
day yes and take a breath and also it's
okay to turn the things off go over to
your older two children who are pulling
the hair and say whoa whoa whoa ouch
that hurts you're having such a hard
time we're going to talk about it and
work this out but right now I know
everybody's hungry we need to get dinner
going so and the baby's crying me while
on your hip and needs to eat or whatever
um and you say so you can you each need
to do different things right now and
then we'll work it out later what are
you gonna do yes you can go in your room
and read your book what are you going to
do yes you can go over there to draw you
know whatever so it's fine to separate
them and work it out later you don't
have to like go through the whole
scenario at this moment right because
you don't have the time to do this yeah
but the difference is not the like the
shaming the blame the guilt the Locking
and that aspect and again when we're
dysregulated we act out of fear and then
we shame and blame and no good for
anybody yes did you finish your no
session
so we we yeah there's so much to say no
right but it's okay to say no but we
always empathize at the same time it's
so hard to stop playing and get ready
for bed and it's time for bed right no
no cookie even if the child's on the
floor crying no cookie and we're not
gonna shame and blame them for that
reaction because in that case it's
probably not about the cookie right so
it's completely fine to hold the
boundaries that are super important
and you said you know people don't feel
comfortable saying no why does my no not
have power also
remember it takes two people to have a
power struggle if your child if you're
listening to this and your child you're
thinking my child gets into Power
struggle with me about everything I
would advise you that it takes two
people to have a power struggle and you
do not have to attend every Power
struggle you're invited to
everything you
use and at that like and I'm I'm
thinking again a four-year-olds because
four-year-olds are very interested in
power they want to know how do I get my
needs met in this big world and they
often are very bossy with their friends
four-year-olds and their bossy with
their siblings and you know if if you're
um
as a parent if you haven't yet learned
to give your child the right to make
decisions about things that are okay for
them to make decisions about
you're probably doing what I would
consider over controlling so I met one
mom who was she was looked like a
fashion model at all times every minute
I don't know how she always looks so
great and her daughter wanted to wear
what she wanted to wear and the mother's
like I can't let her wear flowers and
Stripes together I'm like you absolutely
can what do you care I mean you well
well people would judge her she thought
and I said they will judge you as being
a good mom who lets your daughter
Express herself and they'll know she
dressed herself if she puts those three
things on together and that's fine right
absolutely so so I think sometimes we
have to back off the control if we have
a child who's saying no to us all the
time right because in this case what was
happening was the daughter the mother
would say where the wear this and wear
this and the daughter's saying no I'm
going to wear this and they would get
into a fight over it like really yeah
that's if you want to fight over yeah
you pick your battles on the important
things and then there's also I think at
the four-year-old age too where you kind
of figuring out where where what they
can do and how much they can or can't do
so you might say okay you need to clean
your room and then you'll realize okay
maybe they're not quite ready to clean
their whole room all by themselves and
you're getting a pickle because you want
your node to be your no and you don't
want to oh but it's fine that's a great
example of where you might step back
from your no because you realize it was
unreasonable now yeah so you're saying
no you can't go outside and play with
your siblings until your room is clean
yeah and your kid's like yeah and you
know some four-year-olds maybe could
have handled that maybe your older child
did it when she was four but this one
can't for you know everybody's different
yeah each age so so in that case you say
that is so hard to hear that you need to
clean your room and it feels so
overwhelming yeah it feels so
overwhelming you know what let's figure
it out together yeah let's do it
together I'll help you yeah you and you
want your child to know that you're a
safe place to come back to with what
isn't working for them in life so you
and they've always got back up and you
say we'll figure it out together you say
right give me a hug okay
in a room what we need to do to clean
your room is we need to pick up all the
clothes on the floor and put them in the
hamper and we need to pick up all the
toys and put them on the Shelf uh but
maybe that's the books go here just like
clear simple guidelines yeah they need
to know like the simplest possible thing
yeah everything off the floor toys go on
the Shelf books go on this shelf and
clothes go on the hamper it might be
that simple that may be it that's the
most a four-year-old can probably handle
it's not like they're gonna also
probably make their bed although you
know you could trade in one of those
other things for it but three things is
all anyone can remember certainly a
four-year-old the real point is you're
there with them doing it right there are
some six-year-olds who can't clean their
room up because you know maybe they have
some ADHD and it's hard to focus right
or you know hard to be organized or
maybe they just get distracted so easily
and that's fine to say
oh it feels so overwhelming let's work
on this together we'll figure it out I'm
right here I love that oh it's so good
everything you said about that it's a
good reminder so do you feel like we've
talked enough about parents who are like
when when I say no my child ignores me
yeah I feel like we could go into that a
little bit more there's there is another
thing I would say to parents if you feel
like you're always saying no and your
child ignores you I would wonder if
you're actually standing behind you or
no yeah because notice that I took that
bucket away from the child that
two-year-old I took the bucket away from
him I did it in a really lovely way but
I did it and I did not give the cookie
to the kid and I insisted that the child
clean up their room so if the child is
just saying no like and screens are a
great example of this where parents
expect a child to be able to turn off a
screen now we know better we know that
when we're on a computer busy doing
something and a kid is saying something
we're like yeah go away you know we know
that's our reaction so why do we expect
a child or we know we know that Netflix
is founded on a model and YouTube It's
founded on a model of showing you
something new every time you're done
with something and that we we look we're
like oh that's where binge watching
comes from right adults so how do we
ever expect our 14 year old or a 10 year
old or a seven-year-old to turn off the
screen right it's very hard for them to
do it's a dick
so parents will say well I say no and
she keeps watching the screen yeah you
you have to when the screen is off you
have to have a conversation about that
and how hard it is to turn it off and
don't make them bad and wrong it's it's
all YouTube and Netflix or whatever you
know we we know this is how it works
yeah acknowledging that it is hard yes
exactly and and then say what can I do
to make it easier for you what can we do
to make it easier usually you need
something to go toward
when you turn off the screen it can't be
turned off the screen and do your
homework it has to be turn off the
screen and come and let's have a little
five minute roughhousing session with
each other and laugh and you know
because they always want your attention
right let's do that or it's time for a
snack or it's time to go outside and you
know throw a ball together something
that they're going to look forward to
and even if it's go outside and run
around the house three times or my
daughter used to do push-ups when she
would get off the screen because it was
like it's physical a way to remobilize
that energy into something physical
right so you can always work with your
child on how to turn off the screen but
you have to stand behind it you say
it's very hard for you to turn this off
I know you want to get to the next level
of the game and it's time to turn it off
do you think you can do it or should I
do it and yourself like no no Mom just
wait a minute two more minutes and you
say I hear you want two more minutes you
I would always give one warning like
it's five minute warning the timer just
went off so you have a five minute
warning I'm sending it now for five
minutes because it went off to give us
the the five minute warning and then at
the end of the five minutes when the
case two more minutes two more minutes
you say I know we just had your extra
five minutes so I'm gonna turn it off
um no no Mom just I'm gonna turn it off
I know it's gonna be hard take a breath
and you you do whatever you need to you
can unplug it if that's what you have to
do you turn the thing off and then your
child has a complete meltdown but they
learn you're no just stuck your nose
your no yeah yeah and the difference is
you're not going I'm gonna like you're
not yanking it out of the whatever the
water grabbing it from them in this
horrible way where you're so angry at
them or you're not saying no video games
for a week because you didn't listen
because that's the that's kind of where
I think a parents want to resort to
maybe because they're feeling busy and
they're not feeling like they have the
time to sit down and get on their level
and get on that connection levels that
are like if you don't turn it off right
now you lose your video games tomorrow
tomorrow as they're cooking in the
kitchen but it's that extra effort that
makes all the world a difference because
then over time they know your no is no
and it doesn't have to be a shamey guilt
thing and then it becomes easier yeah in
such a quick time and and that is really
the final word on no is it's all about
the way you say it and the connection
you build as you do it because you can
say
you know you want to do this no we're
not going to do that we're gonna and you
pick them up and throw them around if
they're two you know or or no we're not
going to do that to your 14 year old but
we are going to have some time to you
know do we always do together where we
have a cup of tea yes throw a football
whatever the point is that we're always
standing behind our know with connection
because remember
they want this thing they want that you
just said no to but they want something
else more and that's that relationship
with you and so why are threats so bad
so why because I think that's the most
common way to pair it is if you don't do
this then this is well so think about
what you have to do with threats either
you stand behind the thread and you do
the thread yeah or you don't if you
don't do the threat then why would your
child actually listen to you because
they know and in fact often they know
yeah she's threatening but she's not
yelling really the top her lungs yet and
then finally when she's screaming at the
top of her lungs and grabbing the iPad
out of my hands oh yeah I'll listen to
her now yeah right you teach them the
threats it teaches them that you have to
escalate it really does it teaches them
one way or the other and let me ask you
when you're making I'll ask everyone
listening you're making a threat
you know you're you're of course you're
going to follow through right because
you're always making a threat from a
very reasonable place where that would
be a reasonable thing you would do right
I mean that's crazy you know I'm
thinking of one mom who I was I was on a
phone call with her this is years ago we
were in a group she was she was one of a
few moms in a group I was leading and in
the background we hear her husband
screaming against the kid and the
husband is leaning against the door to
the kid's room holding the door shut and
screaming you're never gonna come out of
that room again it's like right where
are these threats or we're gonna stick
to our threads right you're never going
to follow through with them and I
understand again why parents feel
powerless they feel powerless in the
face of their child saying like whatever
it was and so they they they get
dysregulated they feel that the child is
somehow being disrespectful your child
wasn't disrespectful to not put down the
screen they were addicted to the screen
that may be something you need to work
on but they weren't necessarily it
wasn't about reflection it's not about
you we make it about us too much yeah
you know yeah totally and so I would say
to every parent who's who starts they
hear the threat coming out of their
mouth
stop
drop your agenda
breathe stop drop breathe
take three deep breaths
and start over right start with
connection
maybe it's your 14 year old on the
computer and you say you come over and
you you put your hand on their shoulder
you're connecting and you say whoa Brent
need your attention and Brent looks at
you and says no no Mom not now you say
bread it's time we need to turn it off
you had your extra fighting you know
whatever you need to do but you notice
you've returned yourself to calm before
you begin to interact the minute you
feel threatening you already you know
you're already dysregulating you have to
stop you have to step back stop drop and
breathe and then you can start off
because what you what you said earlier
about what you're teaching them how to
react to you is so key because if you
just go to this pattern of
say no and then they don't listen and
you do the count of three and then you
do the threat and then it just keeps
going and going then they're gonna learn
oh Mom doesn't really mean no until she
gets to that point exactly but if you
just say no and you go over and you have
your connection and then you remove this
whatever the situation is that's the no
yeah and so then they know you don't
have to use anger to say no you just
have to mean your no and follow through
on it and it will always be more
effective if you offer your child
understanding as you do it I know it's
so hard to XYZ whatever it is yeah and
even if you find yourself because I
think a lot of people listening might
find themselves in a place where they
want to implement everything that you're
saying and they're like yes and they
might implement it maybe even 80 of the
time but then they find themselves this
is where I am where I'll find myself
every once while going to that place and
I don't want to go yeah and even if it's
like a threat thing like I'll go back
and be like okay I'm sorry that I don't
know why I said that I was just starting
to lose my cool I didn't mean it I
shouldn't have said that and then start
over and that's something they're like
oh this isn't mom's Norm they learned
from that too because you're apologizing
when you make your mistake even into
something like a threat I love that and
I call it a do-over and as we model it
they learn to do it too yeah so you can
say
oh let's all have a do-over and your
child gets sister I I know you wanted
accent your brother wanted why let's and
we you both said things that hurt each
other's feelings let's have a do-over
and if you've modeled that they can do
it with each other too so good okay any
final takeaways for how we can connect
more with our kids before we end this
I think you look at each child and you
see who they are and how you can
what they need some you know back to
Love Languages you know some kids really
need to be touched other kids it's in
the language you use the words some kids
it's you know referred to as acts of
service that you help them when they're
trying to you know go to the soccer game
and you help them not forget their shin
guards you make the list for them of
what they need and you you before as you
get into the car you say okay where's
your list let's look at that together or
you wash their uniform for them for the
big day or whatever things that are are
um that child might consider to be love
language so we we look at what each
child needs to feel valued and seen and
loved by us I think that's what matters
to connect perfect and I do have one
other thing to say to parents yes
I've mentioned self-compassion
research is pretty clear that when we
are nicer to ourselves we are nicer
people and most parents don't think that
they think well I'm letting myself off
the hook I lost it I yelled at my kids
that was terrible I don't want to be
that person and of course yes yes I want
to give that Mom a hug or that dad a hug
and say of course you don't want to be
that person
and
it's understandable
and if any of us were in your exact
shoes we would have done the same thing
and I mean that I mean with your you
know lack of sleep the night before and
you're you know kids doing whatever they
were doing that moment and your worries
about money or health or whatever else
and and your exact genetics and you know
everything that brought you to this
moment
it was a hard moment there are hard
moments in everyone's life give yourself
that let yourself off the hook
hug yourself as I say we have to
re-parent ourselves that's the big
secret is we have to learn to be our own
parent and give ourselves what we need
and then you know just be kind to
yourself and then say okay
let's replay this just like you did with
your child what could you do with that
Nerf gun instead of shooting in your
brother's face right let's Replay that
what could I do if I'm in this situation
tomorrow well first of all I'm going to
go to bed earlier secondly I'm going to
stop before it gets out of hand and
separate the kids so they're not pulling
each other's hair whatever the thing is
that we need to do so we're not
escalating right at that moment and you
know some as I say parents think they're
letting them people think they're
letting themselves off the hook it turns
out that actually people who are more
self-compassionate
are more loving not just to themselves
but to other people because they have
more love inside that's less shame less
blame more love that's what we need to
do to make the world a better place and
to be the parents we want to be yeah
absolutely all this whole conversation
really centers around like healing us as
people as a collective yes because it
starts with how we're raising our little
babies and how they grow up to be to
raise their babies and so on and how
they treat everybody around them yes and
the children we are raising every day
are going to be the people who will
populate the planet after we're gone and
wouldn't it be an amazing world if all
of them learned how to be more
emotionally generous
yes absolutely this is amazing well
thank you so much for being here I'm so
honored and so thankful to have this
conversation and pick your brain on
things and get new inspiration so I
really appreciate it and you're just
incredible so thanks for being here this
has been so much fun yes and your
children are wonderful oh thank you okay
we're gonna end it now bye
another
[Music]